well thanks to the civil war trailer
Spidey's back on everybody's mind so
let's all talk about that so welcome to
council of geeks my name is Nathaniel
aina i'm joined today by Ryan Daley
thanks for coming in Ryan thank you for
having me so um we were going to talk
about this anyway but the timing had
suddenly become more appropriate because
in the wake of the civil war trailer
there is of course the capper on the end
of that we get to see spider-man we're
not going to dwell on that because that
that is not the main thing we were
coming but just quick thoughts what you
think the look in general I was very
happy with it and it happened so quickly
that all i got was the sense of it the
impression of this veteran and it looks
very very good uh I was taken back by
the brightness of a costume I don't
recall seeing a brighter red on a
superhero costume maybe since the
Christopher Reeve Superman then like and
on the second viewing I was like does it
look washed out does it look overly
rendered or overly CG and then a third
viewing I like that that's fine i liked
the motion of the eyes they're doing the
Deadpool thing where ya eyes are a
little bit more expressive and at first
they're bigger and then they get kind of
narrowing it reminds me of the classic
comics and the costume might go through
some changes I mean captain america's
costume has changed every movie i know
what you think i I liked it and and I
like to despite having told you before
the trailer came out wishing that they
wouldn't do it I I kind of had my secret
hope that they were gonna leave him out
of the marketing altogether um and
having now seen him I'm okay because it
is just this in a moment now i am now
hoping that we're not gonna see any more
of him cuz i mean this this was valid
because anyone who is not like us and
keeping tabs on the thing may not have
been aware that he was in this so okay
so fine he's in there now everybody
knows can we leave it at that place i
will move off from the child cuz I i
have a video up on youtube with my own
thoughts on it you want to get more
complete thoughts you can go to that
what we were always going to talk about
is sort of Spidey's villains sort of
starting with the fact that apparently
the venom solo movie is not as dead as
we may have been led to believe or maybe
had hoped that it was
yeah there's still some rumors going
around i don't think it's official i
don't think it's been announced but that
rumor just kind of popped up recently
that sony is still actively developing
this as a movie approach completely
separate well maybe separate from their
spider-man movies that they're doing
with Marvel venom his entire core
concept is evil spider-man so how do you
do that without the origination it
strikes me as a very smart thing for two
reasons first and foremost I think the
success of Deadpool yeah they can mark
it venom as their dark violent uber like
rated R version of their superhero movie
he is sometimes known as the lethal
protector let us not forget so they will
and I have every confidence that that is
the direction that they will go with it
okay um the other is I think when the
Sony email hacks came out a little bit
more than a year ago they I think they
got gun shy and they felt like they were
pressure to make this deal with Marvel
and it was the best thing for everybody
but now they're sitting on one superhero
franchise that they kind of have to
share with another one meanwhile DC or
water brothers is going to be doing two
or three movies a year Disney's doing 32
or three movies a year Fox is doing two
or three movies a year Sony's like why
are we only doing one or half of one
movie a year we still had all these
plans we're still losing this cash we're
not doing anything with it so I think I
think they still think they can make
money off of a venom movie and I think
they will if they do it I I guess I
guess you've sort of hit some some
notions as to that why why would they do
this and and there are reasons they're
not creative reasons but there are
reasons to do it so I guess the question
then becomes how and I think the only
way that you can do it is to go with one
of the more recent versions of venom you
can't do any Brock because absolutely
even though he is the most iconic venom
absolutely everything about that venom
it ties back to spider-man Eddie's
entire origin and and his motivation
ties to spider-man the suit and its
entire origin and its hatred
ties back to spider-man then they merge
together through a joint hatred of
spider-man now and I don't know if this
is the current version of venom but I I
know certainly recently venom was
basically an agent of the government and
he was um Flash Thompson flash on the
former high school former high school
student turned now veteran missing limbs
I believe he's I think he lost both of
his legs yeah the war so in the Venom
symbiote me like is able to regenerate
those for yes purposes and and they've
got this whole thing going where they
send them out of missions but he gets
very limited time with the suit because
they don't want it corrupting him and I
feel like that version or something
along those lines one of the more recent
interpretations logistically that's kind
of what they're gonna have to do and I
wouldn't have a problem with that if
they went for it I also think it's an i
would not be surprised at all if they
call the protagonist Eddie Brock because
of what little name recognition that
carries now will it be any ready rock
that we recognize from the comics or the
cartoons probably not so much for the
reasons you outlined but I'm the basis
of do people know that venom is Eddie
Brock they might so let's call the
character Eddie Brock so you think we're
going to run into sort of the the modern
flash thing where we're going to call
him Barry Allen but everything about his
personality is Wally West I think
something like that yeah I didn't care
about let him that much when he was more
popular because I like to carnage better
not so oh you poor misguided fool yeah
garnish was red and I like the color red
but that's you know that's it that's as
coherent a reason for liking Carnage's
anything else about why not um so yeah
so venom it's an it's an odd idea but of
course that sort of brings to mind the
other supposedly scrapped maybe they're
not ideas like the Sinister Six movie
and I kind of just brought me to the
idea of talking about Spidey's rogues
gallery in general because you had a
conversation on um I believe it was
secret secret origins podcast you were
talking about Flash's um rogues gallery
and spider-man kind of has the same
thing going which is that his
his robes are really very much geared
towards the comic book format they're
good for one or two issues they've all
got very personal motivations but we're
only a couple of exceptions he's
basically stopping elaborate bank
robbers right bank robbers or stalkers
or people with a very simple revenge
motive yeah but they're not complex
characters their science emote like
gimmicky villains yeah so the question
becomes who's left but we've seen Gavin
in like three of the last five
spider-man movies you've got dr. Otto
Octavius Doctor Octopus one of my
personal favorites he was done so so
well and I think he will be a heavy
hitter but maybe not in the next
spider-man movie that we get to other
villains who I think can carry their own
movie one would be the venom actually
yeah but if they're doing a solo then a
movie that's I think is going I think
we'll probably be rated R or a hard
pg-13 I don't think it will be in the
same unit was good especially if it's
being developed if they go are or not if
they're developing it right now that
that means it's got to come out soon-ish
to understand yeah spider-man movie
comes out so we can assume he's not
going to be inspiring my first he's just
gonna peel and the fourth one would be
Kraven the hunter I think you can get a
good full movie story out of Kraven the
hunter and you can do something like an
adaptation of Cravens last hunt the most
famous story I don't think they should
try to do a straight adaptation of it I
think they can tame it a little bit I
that's an intense story that's a very
intense summer especially if we're
looking at a potential first movie for
this new spider-man that's the thing
with Craven I don't think he works as a
first movie villain I don't think
because he's the kind of villain you
bring in for the second movie to lay
your hero low right the first movie is
the first spider-man movie is not going
to be an origin movie they've said that
they have this character established
already but I um two other villains that
could potentially carry a full movie on
their own with a generous amount of
padding one is the lizard who we already
saw in the first amazing spider-man
movie so I don't think we're going to
see him again yeah and another one
again with a generous amount of padding
I think Mysterio could be used as a full
them but again I don't see that as a
first-round spider-man Mysterio's are
really tough one because the thing is
the the thing about Mysterio is that at
this point he he really kind of only
works as a surprise villain that you
find out it's him at the end because the
instant you know it's him I know what
the gimmick is which is that you can't
trust any illusion so if you know it's
him up front then nothing has any stakes
cuz like well it's all fake right um the
ears ears um well here's the one that I
think would be perfect but I know they
can use which is kingpin kingpin would
actually be perfect because he'd be
perfect ground level good for early
career spider-man and he could hire any
elaborate hitman that you would that you
would care to think of and there are
other gangsters they could use they
could do somebody like a tombstone or
hammerhead just kind of generic names
for them they're not going to have the
gravitas of Wilson Fisk which is yeah
miss but you can do that the other one
that I think might work would be
Alistair Smythe and the spider Slayers I
was going to I was thinking about that
one too and actually just came to me
today and i would actually blend that
with the scorpion now the scorpions
original origin in the comics it was
like spider-man 12 I think was that he
was created in part and funded by J
jonah Jameson mm-hmm now that's a story
that if you do that you can't use J
jonah Jameson anymore but now I think
we'd know enough about ok if this guy
hires a murderer to try and kill this
kid he's not going to be allowed to run
a newspaper anymore yeah but you can
change that you could blend both of
those ideas you can have Smythe make
scorpion as the ultimate spider slayer
or something like that mm-hmm and I
think it's just it's you have a slightly
bulkier look you can do a lot of fun
things with the tail for like visual
gags and for combat so maybe something
like that a combination of scorpion and
or the spider Slayers so I think the one
villain thing that we haven't talked
about and yeah this is something you
build towards yes sony you've built is s
which is the Sinister Six yeah
maybe one of the best super villain
concepts ever and it's something that
you can do with spider-man and not many
other people it shows you how great
spider-man is as a hero that he has to
tackle all of these guys at the same
time but again you don't make a sinister
six solo movie as your knockoff Suicide
Squad or you're a villain team-up movie
it has to be about spider-man overcoming
all of these obstacles thrown on top of
each other and what he can do it's
something you do for your fourth and
final spider-man solo movie in this
franchise I'm assuming we're not going
to see a villain team up in in the first
spider-man movie unless it's a sort of
tech mastermind in his goon or a
gangster mastermind and his goon here's
a thought if we just conceptually take
the Sinister Six hmm and we even think
about what it looked like amazing
spider-man 2 setup which was because we
saw basically the tech for a whole lot
of these guys sort of in one person's
possession sure so what if we got a
sinister six movie where as much as it
kind of on some level hurts me to say
this but I have to at the same time in
med I think it would work what if the
Sinister Six were effectively the
high-tech hit squad the jacked-up
minions of somebody who provided them
with their tech I think I could stomach
that if it was presented well because
again the because most of those guys
their origins are so simplistic and the
motives are so generic yeah if they're
if they're just ex-cons or mercenaries
that are hired and say here here's a
wingsuit you can fly not like a vulture
here here's a weird tale you can be the
scorpion if they do some more moreland
years for more limbs if it did something
like that i could probably stomach that
and work with it now I he could but I'm
of two minds of that because I'm like
that would work complete I think in a
vacuum self-contained with a movie but
that does basically mean you are
downgrading six villains to nothing but
and I and on a creative level that seems
like a bit of a waste especially if your
franchise building the movie still needs
to be about spider-man it needs that
about him at the core yes that's true
and that's still even if you're
streamlining there the motivations and
the setup of how they get their powers
that's still putting a lot of time and a
lot of weight on the villains and mostly
putting the spectacle on the villains
and that is something that Marvel has
really gone aggressively against that's
why that's one of the reasons why a lot
of people complain that they're villains
aren't that memorable and they don't get
brought back is because Marvel's like no
we're spending more than these monies to
keep Chris Evans around him let's make a
movie about 47 if Sony was behind it I
can see them going with your inner track
I think with marvel at exerting more
creative control that's not the way they
would approach certainly not the first
spider-man movie I think we're going to
get one main antagonist possibly a
henchman working for a gangster
mastermind like a hammerhead or or a
Norman Osborn that we just don't see as
a goblin but just sort of a suit or
maybe I would I would be okay with that
because like Octavius sort of building
this tech if I could pick anybody I
wouldn't mind seeing doc ock come back
as the mandolin I don't think he will be
I think they'll hold him back for a
little bit longer I would not object to
him because he's such a great villain by
the time this movie comes out it'll have
been at least 12 years you know since
since we had a doc ock I I think it
might have been enough time that that
they could get away with with doing him
again now that I'm thinking of it I
think that would be my preference
because he is one of the few because he
is an evil genius and not just a bruiser
which is what a lot of these guys are
but you can actually build something
bigger around da car can i I think he'd
probably be the best call now about it
now that I'm sort of talking it out I
think that would be my one-two punch for
the first two spider-man movies Doc Ock
and Craven and or the Spidey Slayers yep
so uh so neat Marvel we have a plan give
us a call you know um so sneaky I'm
giving people calls keeping track of
what drive do Ryan plug o
re podcasts on the fire and water
podcast network the secret origins
podcast power of fishnets a black canary
and zatanna podcast and give me those
Star Wars which is about interestingly
enough Star Wars wow really right no you
can also find my work at Rising Sun
comics com I am the author of the
webcomic red and green co-author i
should say co-creator and the creator
and soul writer of the webcomic my pet
ninja both available at Rising Sun
comics com awesome if you're watching
this video why not check out the council
of geeks podcast where you can hear a
longer uncut version of this thing you
just saw so thanks for coming in Ryan
thank you for having me and thank you
for joining us on this don't forget to
Like subscribe i'm on twitter i counsel
the geeks you can email council of geeks
@ gmail.com and until next time this
council adjourned oh you must come on a
set